um you know last week or maybe it was
the week before
i told you about a report that looked at
how coveted denialism and coveted
conspiracy delusions
have been a great feeder into
anti-semitic conspiracy theories and all
of the different overlaps that exist
about shadow government both being
controlled by jews
and
wanting everybody
injected with tracking devices or you
know whatever the case may be the point
is this report found how online covet
denialism and coveted conspiracies
are very much interlaced with
anti-semitic conspiracy theories and
white supremacy white nationalism etc
now anytime there's a report it can be
sort of abstract and we might not
see or understand in practice the way
that this comes together i have an
example for you that was sent to me by a
few viewers today we're going to be
looking at video here of um from a few
days ago i believe this was wednesday or
thursday of last week this is the
chandler governing board study session
and regular business meeting
and there is a woman who is going to
speak and you're going to listen to her
momentarily and it is really the perfect
storm it's an amalgam of anti-vaxx
anti-mask anti-critical race theory
delusions ignorance shadow government
conspiracism and of course she ties it
all together in a nice little bow
and says it's all the jews folks it's
really all the jews so one race is
responsible the jews are making the
vaccines the jews control the shadow
government the jews control the
pharmaceutical companies and this is
what we're talking about when we say
these are the ways that these things
come together it may be one of the most
insane clips i've seen since this all
started let's just jump right into it
warning you know if you don't want kids
to see this i would understand getting
them out of the room let's listen my
name is melanie rattler
i'm a veterinarian i was a former
teacher in phoenix union high school
district i'm a cloning expert with 35
years experience
and i was a consultant to the cdc i've
owned a pharmacy
so do we know if any of those things are
true she was a vet
she was a teacher
she's an expert on cloning
she was a consultant to the cdc
presumably i don't know on something
related to veterinary stuff and she
owned a pharmacy did she own
a human pharmacy or a veterinary
pharmacy
we don't know if any of it's true i want
to tell you that
um
this vaccine
this coveted vaccine is a deadly poison
that's it i'm just going to tell you
that
everybody that takes it is damaging
their immune system
and
they're talking about this being given
to children now it's going to destroy
them
now
it's already been tested on tens of
thousands of kids in clinical trials and
the kids are fine i need to do more
research on it i'm an expert on it and
i'm telling you that's what it's doing
what's also interesting is that all of
the expertise she claims to have which
includes being a veterinarian consultant
to the cdc pharmacy owner teacher expert
on cloning
none of that relates to vaccines
you would imagine that she would have
mentioned in that litany of expertise
that she's also an expert on vaccines
she didn't
all right the next thing is my next
topic is the crt
um
i agree with what both of these people
said um but you know what
if you want to talk about racism if you
want to bring it in then let's bring it
in let's get to the bottom of
the bottom of it we're talking about
white supremacy
okay let's get to the very bottom of it
every one of these things the deep state
the cabal the swamp the elite you can't
mention it but i will there is one race
that owns all the pharmaceutical
companies and these vaccines aren't safe
they aren't effective and they aren't
free
you know that you're paying for it
through the increase in gas prices the
increase in food prices you're paying
for this
and it's being taken from your money and
given to
these um
pharmaceutical companies
and if you want to bring
race into this it's the jews
so a smattering of applause there as she
ties together
all of these different things inflation
gas prices critical race theory the
vaccines through the pharmaceutical
companies the shadow government
it's all
the jews according to this woman
this is the prototypical example of how
this stuff works and it just works so
well for them it feels
so cohesive and and coherent and logical
um this is this is what we were talking
about last week with the report
about how this this covet stuff feeds
right into the anti-semitism and again
you know the the framing of you're not
allowed to say it but i'm going to
you the same group is in control of all
this stuff the shadow government
and the gas prices the i guess i guess
the jews on the gas stations is what
she's saying and the various products
maybe the most insane clip i've seen
since all of this started